he was a number one pick last year he
had 35 points Friday night against New
Orleans PJ Tucker is really warming up
from the corners cp3 with a basketball
now bender comes out the guarding
mismatch for CP 3 as he puts up the
three he's starting to see that in
repointed better see the sun's going all
out a double teaming James Clark gets
the rebound and he missed the putback
PJ gets the rebound sets up CP 3 team
design cp3 getting a big three
[Applause]
there is very coordinate
it's no surprise when you face this
rocket team and eight is another good
young player we haven't mentioned here
tonight to play along with Booker says
they've got something to build on
here's Austin Rivers he's got another
couple years in it face it he's in this
19th season time he got his going house
[Music]
[Applause]
averaging four threes again Rockets
we'll find out maybe later tonight who
they will play in the first round of the
playoffs
partly with his first three of the game
bird nuggets are playing the Portland
blade on trailblazers tonight him to
Denver wit loses a game or two the
Rockets defense left the giver has a
tough game in Utah after the quarter
game back to my la me next year off the
bench with 16 points
[Applause]
against left there's the double team on
harden quickly took a fella
in the corner to Tucker how about that
that's how you beat a double team
pocket said certainly had an advantage
in the playoffs last year against the
Warriors until Chris Paul went out with
the hamstring
PJ Tucker it is subjective blackouts and
territorial restrictions apply how you
doing up there bill
I'm doing great he keeps making those
three-pointers Michelle it's gonna be
even
PJ Tucker wide open wanted to Khun Bowen
Harney but every year it's hardened and
somebody up well totally about the
consistency
[Applause]
to quit they're trying to play for jobs
Aaron Gordon again now Eric Gordon
Espace michael finley three-pointers
made tonight 26 points
Sampson Elijah Wan did a great job coach
the Cleveland franchise is hard for the
three figure out away and a lot of
people say well that step back is a walk
it isn't there's Harden with another
ball harden step-back three is unguarded
it's a tie
and your house 165 games last season
this is just about the postseason buzzer
and even 47 years in Houston Steve Shaw
30 years in Houston he's in the truck
he's the video operator and believe me I
remember when she was born he's 15 I'm
15 years old
danuel house just keeps making those
three don't forget about
[Applause]
three fleurs-de-lis
[Music]
Gary Clark hips number 26 you bet on the
other side of them so you got to look at
both layers well if you don't like it
stop Houston Rockets 27 threes a new NBA
record
[Applause]